hey 42 here in 536 ad there was a
worldwide dust cloud that blocked out
the Sun for a year resulting in
widespread famine and disease welcome to
the most common reaction for men
confronted by TV licensing enforcement
offices is I thought my wife was dealing
with it a kilogram of house flies
contains more protein than a kilogram of
beef despite popular belief studies show
that men are not more flatulence than
women the ACMA estes is the part of the
back that is impossible to scratch after
george w bush was reelected president in
2004 the number of calls from US
citizens to canadian immigration
authorities jumped from 20 thousand to a
hundred and fifteen thousand a day
Thomas Edison proposed to his second
wife in Morse code until 1857 it was
legal for British husbands to sell their
wives the going rate was 3,000 pounds or
23 thousand pounds in today's money some
species of scorpions survive on just one
meal a year in space you cannot cry
because there is no gravity to make the
tears flow Australia has ten times more
camels than koalas in 1987 American
Airlines saved forty thousand dollars by
removing one olive from each salad in
first class the statue Winston Churchill
in Parliament Square is electrified to
stop pigeons from perching on its head
Bill Clinton was mauled by a sheep at
the age of eight and didn't learn to
ride a bicycle until he was 22 to
protect with this public image Google
owns hundreds of / domain
including google poof comm and Google
sucks comm Victorian guidebooks advised
women to put pins in their mouths to
avoid being kissed in the dark when
trains went through tunnels thanks for
the view subscribe for more 42